I've been asked to give a lecture at my
old school
not just any lecture but a lecture in
the memory of famous old boys Sir Henry
Tizard now these series of lectures had
been going on for more than 50 years
when I was at the school I went to the
lectures and I had no idea who Henry
Tizard was or what he'd done so I
thought for this lecture before I give
it I ought to find out who he was and
what he's done it turns out that like me
he was a chemist but his research was
very much dominated by the First World
War and the Second World War which
spanned his life and in the First World
War he became involved in the study of
fuels for aircraft engine you've got to
remember that during the First World War
the planes were very flimsy and were
driven by engines that had just been
invented and therefore nobody quite knew
what was the right sort of fuel and it
turned out that petrol/gasoline that
came from oil from Pennsylvania and the
United States was particularly good but
because of the submarine warfare the
supply of Pennsylvania oil was very low
Tizard started investigating what other
fuels could be used Pennsylvania oil
consists of hydrocarbons these are
chains of carbon hydrogen that are
relatively straight for some reason they
worked well but Tizard for some reason
that's not clear from his obituary
decided to mix this with a mixture of
aromatic hydrocarbons these are carbon
rings of six carbon atoms which he got
from Gas Works the place that makes gas
for carbon monoxide and hydrogen out of
coal and that this mixture when put in
aircraft engine worked even better than
the Pennsylvania oil and nobody knew why
but there was a problem
the major component was benzene which
freezes above naught degree centigrade I
think it's a six degrees centigrade so
when the plane went high in the air and
it was cold it tended to freeze in the
fuel pipes which obviously causes some
embarrassment of suddenly your fuel
pipes freeze but he discovered that
toluene worked much better this is
methyl benzene which has a much lower
melting point but then he was in
conflict with the people that were
making explosives which also uses
toluene but that was sorted out and then
he went on after the first world war to
start studying how airplane engines
could be made more efficient and I was
quite excited I found that he gave a
lecture in the 1920s in 1924 the year my
family came from Russia in which he made
three points the first thing was that
the Air Force was a necessity countries
needed planes to defend them but civil
aviation those a passenger aircraft was
a luxury and his third point which I
think is really interesting he said
flying is unsafe probably more dangerous
than mountaineering that safer than
motor racing and so the point of his
lecture was that aircraft engine had to
be made even more efficient and planes
had to be made mechanically more
reliable and much safer which in fact is
what has happened now which is why we
can all fly all over the world in
relative safety
compared to flying in the 1920s
preparing for this lecture I also
discovered that we had several things in
common
obviously we both went to the same
school then I discovered that he had
been unwell when he sat his final exams
at university he did really well I did
rather badly and then I also discovered
that later in his life he became the
foreign secretary of the Royal Society
the you
okay Academy of Sciences and I now the
Foreign Secretary of the Royal Society
so we have that in common
did you look alike we didn't really look
alike at all we both wore glasses but he
had the moustache and very little hair
and I suspect he didn't move his hands
when he spoke but I suppose the final
points which still worries me slightly
is that when I was a schoolboy and I
went to the Tizard lectures there were
famous scientists giving these lectures
in dark suits and I didn't really
understand why I was there and there's
just a hope that perhaps the present
students will feel differently
I'll also be going along to the lecture
with Professor Polyakov hopefully I
won't be wearing a dark suit but I will
be taking my camera and I'll be showing
you guys a bit behind the scenes at his
school and hopefully maybe some of the
lecture